[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings the united
nations says 3 million ukrainians have
now fled their country since the start
of this russian invasion you know it's
day 20. the majority of those refugees
have crossed into poland many through a
checkpoint near the city of madika cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
that's nora o'donnell is reporting from
near the polish border with ukraine noor
good morning to you i watched your
pieces last night it's the thing with
the children that gets to everybody
every time
gail you know as a mother and as a
grandmother i mean it's hard to travel
with children imagine traveling for days
with no food and with water i mean it's
just been tough to talk to many of these
mothers and kids and and you know as
this war escalates the more ukrainians
are leaving their homes in search of
safety and there's people all over the
world that are coming here to this
country to try and help those millions
that are fleeing the war
every day they come by the thousands
women and children bringing whatever
they can carry out of the war zone
alona and katya traveled from hard-hit
harkeev with their three young children
going hundreds of miles without food to
settle in a country they barely know
at the border volunteers serving hot
meals line the path waiting for the cold
and hungry
volunteers like cami who came from
chicago with united six the whole world
is watching right now trying to figure
out what it is that we can do these
people really need a lot more support
and just acknowledgement of like we're
here for you we support you and we stand
with you they're feeding people like
masha and her five-year-old son benjamin
how are you doing
oh i'm sorry her husband is back in sumi
one of the cities under assault by
russian forces
i'm sorry
and as the war rips families apart
ukrainians are bringing whatever family
they can and helpers are waiting for
them too about how many pets do you
think you've treated here
600 pence did last week i think and what
are you treating them for yeah the
hypertamia the pets are freezing cold
the pets are freezing cold at the border
family stopped to rest and recover
before moving on to the next refugee
center they can grab diapers and shoes
or toys for the little ones
we found this polish soldier helping
yulia holding her child in his arms
lightening her load if only for a little
while
[Music]
but amid the kindness there are those
trying to take advantage of the
vulnerable it's very obvious from the
attempt it's old guys trying to pick
young girls so you can assume it's old
guys trying to get young girls
mohamed rafat is with the united nations
organization for migration he says
they're increasingly concerned about
trafficking of ukrainian women have
there been arrests
for human trafficking yes
here yes
you know and as if the refugees didn't
have enough to worry about their safety
officials at the border were telling us
they're trying to protect women and
girls they say do not get into cars
offering rides make sure you get on
those official buses that will bring
them to safety tony galen vlad
yeah we started hearing about that last
week tony when you were talking about
attacks on women and you're so right nor
that's the last thing you need to worry
about during this particular time
there's always somebody who will take
advantage of a terrible situation but
earlier in this newscast we just talked
about the polish prime minister and
diplomats from czech and slovenia that
are going to keeve today that is quite
quite a show of solidarity can you tell
us what that means
yeah i mean you said it it is an
enormous show of solidarity those three
prime ministers heading into a war zone
heading into kiev just think about on
the day as charlie daggett had just
reported earlier in the broadcast that
they're experiencing some of the most
heavy bombing of this entire conflict
europe is trying to send the signal once
again they are united they stand with
president zielinski and the ukrainian
people and of course gail this comes
just before uh the president of ukraine
is going to address congress you know
that's going to be extraordinary once
again pleading for help from the war the
world to stop this war gail yeah and nor
and nor there is so much need i mean
sometimes the best answer is no answer
at all the interview you had with a
woman where all you say is how are you
doing and and she starts crying that's
one that's going to stay with me thank
you very much for your coverage